there a difference in filming like a
Disney plus series versus an MCU movie
I don't know yet
Loki season one that's one scene we shot
it for three days the thing you have
Kang in quantumania where I'm there from
beginning to end it was different it was
different but it was also different I
think in a different country and on
stuff you know
um no it's the same you know it's
ultimately it's the same in a fight no
Gauntlet Thanos versus King who will
kick who's ass
I don't think I want to start no
problems but I
Marvel movies and my and perhaps like
one of the most sciency ones are you
good at signs at all I'm gonna say yes
but now I'm nervous to say that but yeah
yeah I'm good at science okay because I
have a pop quiz for you uh Jonathan
Michael
um
in your own words uh describe quantum
theory
ah Jesus nope I'm gonna skip that